georgi aussi pour tous les lieux
culturels et notamment les châteaux
prémices d'une saison en forme de point
d'interrogation les visiteurs seront ils
au rendez vous comment les sites
prépare-t-il l'été on en parle avec
notre invité ce soir on soir cécile de
saint venant dans sa forme vous êtes la
directrice de la communication de la
marque et du mécénat du domaine de
chambord
on va tout de suite regardé ces images
tournées cet après midi au domaine on
imagine peut-être une certaine émotion
ce matin pour tous les salariés du
château qui ont vu ces visiteurs
déambuler pour la première fois depuis
des mois une très grande émotion une
très grande joie effectivement pour les
agents de chambord 40% d'entre eux
étaient au chômage depuis quasiment sept
mois maintenant et c'est vrai qu'on
était tous très émus et très il y avait
une vraie une joie profonde c'était
vraiment de la joie alors justement qui
sont ces visiteurs du premier jour rémy
cartons les interviewés on écoute ça
fait du bien et puis avant c'était
c'était pas aussi meublé là ils ont
ils ont bien rénové enfin ça a été
refait récemment je crois desjardins est
en tout cas en partie
donc ça fait ça fait du bien et puis ça
fait plaisir de voir un peu du
patrimoine français ont connu de
charlesbourg depuis longtemps on revient
assez régulièrement dans la région et
c'est toujours un plaisir de visiter
c'est quand même gigantesque c'est assez
féerique quoi on n'était jamais venu ici
et on s'est dit c'est l'occasion faut y
aller
voilà même avec la météo faut y aller on
y va du mercredi cécile de saint venant
après six mois de fermeture c'est donc
quasiment une nouvelle saison qui
recommence comment attirer de nouveaux
touristes est ce que le château de
chambord peut se reposer sur sa
réputation alors le château de champion
ne peut pas se reposer ni sur effet
réputation nice rien du tout donc il
faut toujours aller conquérir de
nouveaux de nouveaux visiteurs nouveau
public cette année c'est évidemment
l'éditeur français et aussi beaucoup les
visiteurs de la région qu'on essaie de
faire venir à chambord avec plein de
nouveautés
une visite guidée des potagers qui a
lieu tous les jours le spectacle
équestre aussi qui a repris ce matin en
demi jauge bien sûr donc tout est mis en
place nous dit voilà il ya une
exposition d'art contemporain qui
commencent dans quelques semaines et
l'artiste peint tous les jours en public
de 16 heures à 18 heures en ce moment
elle s'appelle lydie arickx est
formidable elle aime discuter avec le
visiteur les visiteurs on essaie de
créer de la vie est de permettre aux
gens de venir passer une journée
complète dans des conditions évidemment
sanitaires tout à fait strict mais avec
quand même du rêve et de l'espoir
la jauge est forcément réduite est ce
que c'est rentable pour vous d'ouvrir
maintenant alors la question de la
rentabilité ne se pose pas encore
aujourd'hui on a atteint les 1000
visiteurs pour une première journée on
était assez heureux qu'ils ne soient pas
plus nombreux puisque l'idée c'était de
se roder les premiers jours que chaque
personne chaque salarié reprenne sa
place dans de bonnes conditions donc
finalement c'était une journée pas
l'objectif du chiffre n'était pas là en
tout cas pour nous il n'était même pas
fixé en fait c'est parce que c'est plus
d'un million de visiteurs chaque année
voilà là
normalement en temps normal aujourd'hui
on est entre 3 et 4000 visiteurs par
jour on les a pas du tout atteint
aujourd'hui ce n'était pas le but
d'ailleurs on était plutôt heureux de
chacun reprenne son poste et que les
visiteurs soient accueillis dans de
bonnes conditions sans stress sans
angoisse pour personne en un mot ce que
vous savez à quel horizon vous allez
retrouver une fréquentation voilà qui
était aussi forte que celle de 2019 2017
et recel de 2019 c'était fantastique on
a fêté dans 500 ans et une fréquentation
exceptionnelle à l'année suivante
évidemment comme pour tous les sites
ça a été très compliqué mais on a la
dernière atteint on a perdu 50 % de
fréquentation puisque on a 45% lascars
étrangers c'est pas cette année c'est
évident après qui le sait je ne le sais
pas en tout cas mais c'est évident que
les français vont avoir un très beau
rôle à jouer on a besoin des visiteurs
un lieu comme chambord comme tous les
lieux du val de loire s'ils ne sont pas
vus il n'existe pas merci beaucoup
cecily de saint-renan directrice de la
communication du château de chambord
d'être venu ce soir sur notre plateau